beaucoup reconnaissent déjà j'imagine
macao sur le présent mhk mischer
performeuse de l'extrême et c'est bien
devant une salle vide que l'isle d'abeau
qu'elle est en représentation longtemps
convient débat c'est ça on peut répéter
on peut créer des choses et puis ça
donne un peu de dents vie de joie de
vivre autant que faire se peut mais
qu'at elle avec moi quand même offert de
créer un spectacle même sans savoir s'il
a envie de désir la municipalité de
cheverny accueille en résidence la
préparation d'une nouvelle performance
j'ai choisi comme lieu la la
stade de france un théâtre de l'absurde
qui tourne autour de 300 kilos de sable
entre le sable qui s'écoule dans le
sablier du temps et les pâtés de sable
de l'enfance le matériau sable offre un
accessoire insolite sur une scène de
théâtre
le matériau il a une texture un poids il
a une façon de vivre qui est en fait que
j'utilise vraiment comme un partenaire
de jeu aussi alors pas tout le temps pas
tout le spectacle mais il ya des moments
où il ya notamment un moment qui dure
assez longtemps ou le centre de ce fait
c'est vraiment le sable et son son poids
et sa qualité quoi de sable et je le
prends comme un partenaire les pieds en
prise avec la mollesse vous vous
élèverez bien que mal une création en
résidence qui est aussi l'occasion de se
rappeler au bon souvenir des
organisateurs de festivals
moi j'ai beaucoup ri dans son dernier
spectacle et un rire avec beaucoup
d'ironie et de second degré se saisit de
l'espace et du temps
assez forte et puis a manifestement une
une passion pour tout ce qui est minéral
la terre l'argile le sable que j'ai hâte
de voir la suite
le limon le quartz et le vélo granit
mais le foot c'est vraiment un rapport
des corps nus sur la plage
mais en même temps il ya le pendant
négatif qui est celui de se faire
enterrer vivants qui est un tout petit
peu moins agréable
même en l'absence de public dans
l'incertitude
linda bockel fonce vers son destin de
performeuse de l'extrême vous deviendrez
sable d'une certaine façon c'est l'étape
a juste avant la poussière vous ne
sortirez pas indemne d'une telle épopée
probablement pas probablement par n'ont
probablement pas la mieux